hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game uh the game itself is
from the uh 1963 uh georgian
championship and it's between owner
gamer and dashville and alexander
blagidze you guys said that you would
enjoy uh seeing more of nona's games and
the previous one uh nona lost uh but of
course she faced a former world champion
mikhail tal uh but here is uh an example
of what can happen uh when uh you played
against nona when you weren't uh a
player of
thousands caliber uh but alexander is
incredibly strong player he's a three
times georgian champion he won the
georgian championship in 1950 1953 and
1957 and like i said this is a game from
the 1963 championship so it's quite
amazing uh let's check it out i would
just like to mention the uh the game was
sent to me by chess historian olympia
urkan he said that i i should check it
out that it's quite a nice game and
the title is also from his article the
nona goes nuclear article which i will
link in the description below it's the
first thing you will see
and also i could not find a one photo of
alexander blaguetz accepted this one but
this one i was behind the paywall so i
had the i had to make a choice of using
the hoodie guy or paying ten dollars for
for this very nice photo of alexander
blagitza i decided to pay the ten
dollars so this is one of the
it could be the only video that actually
has production costs i've made so far
and i've made over 3000 videos i believe
or or maybe two thousand i don't know
i've made a lot of videos uh but i just
thought you guys uh i might find it that
interesting uh but uh aside from that uh
not only is he is he a three times um a
georgian champion he also had a nice uh
game against tigran petrossian he drew
against um against him and he also has a
very nice win against none other than
rashid nejmed dinov and he faced many
many other strong players but just
wanted to uh talk a little bit about him
before we check out the actual game
because the the game uh there is no
better word to describe this game the
game the game is actually nuclear so
let's check it out nona with the white
pieces opens with e4 and uh we have a c5
by blagitsa going for the sicilian
defense and nona mentions that uh
usually he's a french player and it was
in fact in the french defense that he
defeated rashid medinav
and well it's not easy attacking the
french you know many have tried many
have failed you know if you remember a
certain game bobby fischer played i was
the only game he lost in that tournament
of you know against uh
a certain guy from from these areas uh
but okay now let's continue the game
knight to c3 uh we have knight to c6 and
now f4 going for the grand prix attack
we have g6 and now bishop to b5 putting
pressure on the knight here uh knight
study for now attacking the bishops okay
black wastes the move white will waste a
move as well bishop back to c4 and
bishop to g7 now we're gonna develop the
nice play some pawn moves maybe castle
and so on
uh we have knight g to e2 uh and now e6
kind of preparing queen to h4 because if
the knight ever moves then the f4 pawn
could fall uh but uh governor dash
really said that she knew her opponent
uh kind of well not i knew him knew him
maybe but she knew what was his style
and she said that he could not resist
going after the pawn so she decided to
go for the spawn sacrifice so knight
captures on the 4c capture sunday for
attacking the knight the other knight
goes to e2 kind of defends the f4 pawn
and now queen the h4 with check and now
you could play g3 uh kicks the queen
away it keeps the f4 pawn safe and uh
okay you weaken the light squares a
little bit but you can still have the
light square bishop it's not really
where it should be anymore but you know
maybe it's playable uh but nona decides
to play knights to g3 and give up the f4
pawn and this is where the fun really
begins uh queen captures on f4 blaguita
accepts the pawn sacrifice and now d3
nicely developing the bishop and you
don't have to worry about queen to c7
coming with tempo so queen to c7 was
played
and now no not just castles so for the
price of this one pawn you have a knight
rook and bishop
in the game uh you you have very natural
square for developing your dark square
bishop the queen can easily go into the
game g4 f3 are available so white
definitely has compensation so knight to
e7 preparing the castle and now again
developing with tempo bishop g5 not
allowing black the castle the knight
would hang
so here you might uh consider a lot of
moves you could play d6 you could play
queen to c5 you could play you could
play a lot of moves but um
queen c5 is actually very interesting it
defends the knight and puts pressure on
the bishop on g5 now you could counter
it with queen to d2 and the game
continues however here knight the c6 was
played and it makes sense the c6 square
is such a natural square for the knight
you no longer have this target on e7
you're ready to castle but there is one
move that allows nona to go for this uh
amazing amazing attack that uh well it
is just uh unlike something we've seen
on this channel except maybe in tal and
rashid's game so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
amazing idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's knights
the h5 that's that's the movie yes it
looks really weird and it doesn't seem
like a forcing move at all because you
could just say okay i'm just gonna
ignore the knight let's say you castle
but it's now a dead lost position now
white just captures the bishop king
captures the bishop to f6 check no good
moves here king the g8 and now queen to
d2 and now queen to h6 followed by queen
to g7 checkmate is unstoppable because
black's dark squares are just a mess so
the other thing you could do after
knight to h5 is say all right uh
it's a weird move i'm gonna play a weird
move as well maybe maybe counter the uh
then i did this way now the knight can't
really go anywhere my bishop covers all
of these squares and the knight is still
attacked the problem is knight to f6
check now bishop captures bishop
captures and now white is positionally
white positionally already won there are
so many dark square weaknesses around
the black king
and black has nothing to counter this
beautiful dark square bishop with and
again queen to d2 is coming you're gonna
uh
bring that queen into the game and
there's nothing for this king to do he
can just wait and see what happens so
the only way to counter this uh you know
amazing weird move is to accept the
night sacrifice so we have pawn captures
knight uh and now how do you continue
here uh well there is but one move rook
captures on f7 now we sacrificed the
rook and this uh
uh this uh rook sacrifice cannot be
accepted uh later uh nonna also um uh
did annotation in this game and she
showed a way for for uh black to kind of
hold this position but we're gonna get
back to that i hope i remember this uh
so rook captures on f7 and now what do
you play if you accept this king
captures on f7 well then it's just queen
to h5 check and there's no hope for you
whatever you do uh just runs into
checkmate if you go kinked uh g8 and
then queen to e8 check or if you go king
of f8 first rook to f1 check so
everything loses but okay just to show
you queen eight check we're going to
block with the bishop now rook f1 and
there's no defense it's either a queen
to f8 checkmate or queen to f7 checkmate
you cannot defend against both
so uh what you could do here uh is try
something else okay maybe we can't
capture the rook what do we play here uh
well here uh queen e5 was played but now
uh there is
such a such a cool move that
can be played here so feel free to pause
the video for the second try a second
time and try to find this brilliant win
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not capturing
the h5 pawn with the queen uh we're
going to discuss this no worries but for
those of you who found the actual move
then truly congratulations the movie is
rook to f5 you are an amazing attacker
much like tal or nishmedinov uh now it
was uh
we only have the pgn up until this point
we don't have the rest of the game but
as nonna explains black resigned in
about a few moves so it doesn't really
matter because whatever you play here
you are completely dead lost there is no
move you can play here queen captures on
h5 is just a terrible threat and there's
no way to counter it if you accept the
rook sacrifice then you open up this
light square bishop diagonal the dark
square bishop diagonal is completely
crushing and then it's just a queen
captures on h5 check king to f8 and now
queen to f7 checkmate so nothing really
uh
going on
for black there another thing black
might try is give up the queen with
queen captures on f5 uh okay then we
accept the queen for example now black
and castle and you get this position but
still it's completely winning for white
uh move like f6 and there's not much you
can do bishop captures we're gonna
capture on h5 and uh well rook to f1 is
now coming this is just completely lost
captures captures with check we're gonna
move let's say we attacked the rook the
rook is gonna move now we play rook to
f1 and now rook to f7 followed by
checkmate or something like that
it's completely unplayable you could
play knight e5 blocking this rook to f7
id and now we play h3 simply not to
allow knight to come to g4 if we if we
play rook to f7 uh or
not if you play rook to f7 we can play
that but we don't want to allow a move
like this so here whatever black plays
next move we go with rook to f8 and now
how do you defend there's nothing you
can do queen to f6 will be checkmate so
you have to play this the kind of block
or rather even knights to g6 just to
block this uh and now we're gonna play
rook to f7 go after the pawn here knight
to f8 defending and now queen to f6
check followed by checkmate so this is
not happening so uh after rook to f5
there is no move that black can play uh
and of course uh like nona mentions it
was a
only in a few moves that black resigned
the game and if you move the black queen
somewhere it doesn't really matter where
just queen to h5 check is made in one
and
there's no uh square for you left the
bishop covers this the rook covers f8
it's completely lost
so i would just like to mention uh that
position uh that nonna also mentions
after rook captures on f7 that there was
a one
one move that allows black to defend uh
but it's uh such a tricky move uh the
move is of course h6 this is the move
that holds for black but it's so uh so
ugly that uh
well now the point is if queen captures
on h5 now we seem to play h characters
on g5 and we have no useful discoveries
because our queen is hanging so there
really isn't um
anything good for us here if we play
some like queen to g6 to try and keep
the tension and try to do some damage
queen captures on h2 and then well white
is just in big trouble so after h6 uh
there really is no good way for white to
continue the attack you have to move the
bishop and then the game continues for
example bishop f4 we're gonna play
bishop to e5 now just threatened to
capture it as our queen was attacked and
if queen captures an h5 now king to d8
and black survives perhaps of course in
in a perfect world uh that's why she
says that black has chances of defense
and not that black actually has a
defense but yeah h6 in this position
could hold yeah but it would only ruin
this masterpiece so in the actual game
we're just going to remember it with
rook to f5 uh this is the end position
you you guys are going to show to your
friends at the bar in the library so
there we have it rook f5 and the black
resigned
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh thank you uh olympia
for sending me this brilliant gem and uh
i hope you guys enjoyed that as well and
hope you guys enjoyed the photo of
alexander blagitza as this is like i
said the only video that actually has uh
production cost that that i've made
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and this blistering win uh by
nonna so we don't only have the loss to
tal but we also uh have this where you
know she just crushes the three times
the georgian champion and someone who uh
played so many so many impressive
players and you know some of them he
defeated some of them he drew something
he lost but she just completely crushed
him so that's the kind of player that
nona was and no wonder that she wanted
to play such a such a fierce game
against misha
so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank raikon hong antoine
bull daniel silverberg shanti changanti
and mathias binte for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and uh i will check of
course on everything else that's
happening in the chess world so thank
y'all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day